- Entre l'hôpitalraine,raine,ra,
il y a des milliers
omètres.
Mais les horreurs de la guerre
résonnent fort dans le coeur
- Moi, je ne pouvais pas vivre
avec lavec lavec le fait de resr
ici les bras croisés.
- Hanté par les imagesspiré par
le courage des Ukrainiens,
Dr Auger a pris sa décision :
il va bientôs le pays
pour leur prêter main forte.
Il répond à l'appel
du gouvernement ukrainien,
qui a besoin de renfort
civils et combattants.
Pour ce père de deux enfants,
quitter le Québec est
Dr JULIEN AUGER, médecin, Centre
hospitalier de Saint-Jérô
- C'est sûr que l'annonce
à ma famille, c'est pas... c'est
pas qur au nivear au nivear au e
je puisse aller là et être en
je me sens tellement interpellé,
t'sais, au plus profond de moi.
- Certains veulent soigner et
d'autres sont prêts à combattre.
"Les roquettes russes tuent des
innocents. C'est de la folie",ie
ukrainienne. Il songe à vendre
sa mait amasser
le plus d'argent possible avant
de partir. À s
est sur le champ de bataille.
"Ici, je ne pe, je ne pe, je ,
dit-il.
du président ukrainien trouve
écho chez des Oc
Mais arriver en zone de guerre
mal préparé est très risouligne.
- Ça va être ensuite la barri
de la langue et l'apprentissage
- Des pays comme le Royaume-Uni
et l'Australie ont clairement
tenté de dissuader leurs
citoyens de voyager pour prendre
les armes en Ukraine.
Le gouvernement Trudeau,
pour sa part, réitère
son avertissement.
CHRYSTIA FREELAND, vice-première
ministre du Cana
- On était vraiment très clair
avant la guerre que la situation
en Ukraine est vraiment tr
très dangereuse.
- Mais maintient qu'il s'agit
d'une décision personnelle.
CHRYSTIA FREELANemière
ministre du Canada
- Nous sommes un pays libre,
un pays dans laquelle on
respecte les choix personnels.
- Ottawa
ANITA ANAND, ministre
de la Défense nationale
- Le choix de partir là, ça,
c'est un choix individuel.
- Ottawa a surtout le devoir
de bien expliquait les dangers,
on.
STÉPHANE BERGER,
porte-parole du Bloc québécois
- Ça dépasse les limites
de l'Ukraine, ça concerne
tout le monde, je pense,
dans le monde démocratique.
Si on veut prptéger l'ordre
mondial qu'on connaît depuis
la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
je pense qu'il faut
qu'on s'implique plus.
- Pour lui, cette cause
l'emporte sur sa propre
sécurité.
Ici Louis Bloui